s'ajoute à une liste déjà assez langlade
candidats où il ya sept autres personnes
qui sont officiellement dans la course
on va commencer par les femmes si vous
le voulez bien avec cette personne qui
s'est déclaré il ya quelques jours c'est
tout le single board est d'origine
indienne c'est la représentante de
l'état d'hawaï et la 37 ans assez
dynamique assez jeune mais quelques
casseroles peut-être elle a tenu des
propos homophobes dans le passé elle a
rencontré aussi le tyran de la syrie
bachar al assad donc il ya quand même
des affaires un peu controversé qu'elle
se dit libre en deçà c'est la sénatrice
qui a succédé à hillary clinton dans
l'état de new york et la 52e internet
une sénatrice assez progressistes quand
même et la quatrième femme c'est
évidemment elizabeth warren un peu la
bête noire si vous voulez de donald
trump qui n'arrête pas de l'appeler
pocahontas à cause de sa proximité avec
des autochtones dont c'est la sénatrice
du massachusetts et la 69 ans il ya
d'autres personnes quatre autres hommes
le plus connu d'entre eux on va dire
c'est julian castro qu'il a déjà été
dans le cabinet de barack obama il a 44
ans il vient du texas les autres
personnes c'est un peu moins connus john
de l'année par exemple il vient du
maryland il a 55 ans d'un ancien
politicien il y aussi richard à djeddah
en virginie occidentale et puis un
dernier qui n'a pas vraiment rapport
avec la politique c'est un entrepreneur
qui lui voudrait imposer le revenu
minimum garanti de 1000 $ pour tous les
américains il a 44 ans il pourrait y
avoir d'autres grands noms des poids
lourds en fait du parti démocrate qui
pourrait devenir candidat exactement
céline évidemment on pense tout de suite
à joba et john ince était le colistier
de barack obama l'ancien vice-président
bon 76 ans ça commence à être un peu
plus compliqué pour lui pour essayer de
renouveler un peu le parti vous avez
aussi une des vedettes montantes que
huit boucles du parti démocrate
il est du new jersey il a 49 ans très
progressiste également très libérale
boris enders peut-être on sait jamais 77
ans sénateur du vermont et puis bientôt
works qui a failli gagner un siège au
texas il a failli donc c'est peut-être
pas très bon pour la suite des choses
parce qu'il n'a pas gagné donc mais en
tout cas c'est un nom qui revient assez
souvent
il ya d'autres personnes aussi d'anciens
gouverneurs il ya des mères qui vont
peut-être également mettre leur nom dans
le chapeau du côté des indépendances
intéressant de voir que lui au départ il
pourrait peut-être devenir un candidat
démocrate mais ça n'a pas marché c'est
l'ancien pdg de hoag chose
il pourrait se présenter comme
indépendant et finalement du côté des
républicains c'est assez facile ce
donald trump propre candidat à sa
succession
voilà merci vous en prie